Show more humility
when someone's talking to you!
As someone with authority--
Okay, okay! Below the knee, right?
Understood!
You fool! What is with that swing!
You're going to damage the ears of wheat!
-You said below the knee!
-What is going on?
He's getting yelled at like crazy.
He's Olmar, the master's son.
Oh, they're father and son…
I can't take this anymore!
For once I decide to help you out,
but all you do is nitpick on the details.
I'm done.
I was going to work, but never mind.
Hey! Where do you think
you're going, Olmar?!
Away from you, you old man!
In time, you will be inheriting this farm.
Act more responsibly.
When did I ever ask you
to let me inherit it!
I'm a grown man!
I don't have time to be doing teeny-tiny
insignificant jobs out in the field!
I'm going to use this…
Huh?
-Hey, what is he doing?
-I wonder…
I'll rise up the ranks with this sword!
-Damn it!
-Olmar! Wait, you little…